I tried to get a lie past me so he took
his car to school in the morning and the
school calls me in the morning he was
like Jacob's late and it was like easily
an hour after school was supposed to
start like what do you want to do I go
I'll talk to him
so he walks in the door
and I go hey man and he was yo I go
school call said you were like getting
to school he was like yeah I won't
I know what happened he was I got stuck
behind a parade
[Music]
7 A.M
in front of the school he goes yeah I
thought it was pretty weird too
I go so everybody in schools ladies know
I was the last car to make it
and he goes I watched all the floats he
even went floats I go what parade was it
he was like I don't know they seemed to
be celebrating everything